ومن تل ابيب ينضم الينا ايريكارت
سكيرونسكي بحث في المعهد الاسرائيلي
للديمقراطيه اهلا بك يا سيدي على فرانس
فانك فلنبدا بتصريحات بنيامين نتنياهو كيف
له ان يتحدث عن تحقيق السلام مع العرب
كاولويه وفي الوقت نفسه يتعهد بالمضيق
قدما في سياسه الاستططان
الرئيس الحكماء رئيس الحكومه عن عمليه
السلام هو بيحصد الى السلام بالمعنى
الاوسع اي عمليه السلام او التتبيع مع
العالم العربي طبعا لا نحن لا نرى مجال
لمضيع قدوما بعمليه السلام الخاصه بالمسار
الفلسطيني وخاصه عندما يكون الاختلاف همم
يدمج او يكون في داخل عناصر وهي معارضه
لمفهوم السلام مع الفلسطينيين
المنظمات الحقوقيه راينا بانها تعتصم منذ
الصباح امام الكنيسه لتمديد همم هذا المنح
الديني المتطرف الذي تتخذه هذه الحكومه ما
ماده قدره حكمه نتنياه
الصمود امام هذا الراي العام وهل ستقود
هذه المعارضه الى الانتخابات السادسه اخرى
في اسرائيل
المفاجاه للمفارقه الكبيره انه طابع
الحكومه الحاليه الجديده هي ليست حكومه
متجانسه كما يظهر في للوهله الاولى لانه
الحكومه تكمن في داخلها عناصر تقريبيه
لليمين ولكن هناك عناصر دينيه او عناصر
متدينه واكثر ميولا الى اليمين فنحن نعلم
نعلم جيدا انه نتنياهو عمل جاهدا من ان
يخلق هذا التوحيد الصفوف همم قبل
الانتخابات ولكن اسرائيل مارد بخمس معارك
انتخابيه شرسه في اقل من اربع سنوات
الوضع الاقتصادي
فكيف يمكن لهذا الحكومه ان تكون كل
المشاكل الله اعلم ولكن الحكومه عندها
القدره همم
الاغلبيه القافيه داخل البرلمان اللي هو
ايه تحاول ان تفعل بهدوء نسبيا ولكن همم
من جهه ثانيه هناك همم اهتزازات شعبيه
عامه ومن شانها ان تتزايد في الفتره
القريبه سؤال اخير وهذه نقطه الاستفهام
الكبيره بنسبه لبقيه العالم كيف
للاسرائيليين ان يصوتوا على حكومه بهذا
ال- المنحه المتطرف او بهذه الغالبيه
اليمنيه القريبه من التطرف ما الذي حدث هل
كان هناك عزوف عن التصويت ام ان
الاسرائيليين يريدون او يحبون التصويت
يمينا
ويطمئنون له
غالبيه الاسرائيليون صوتوا الى اليمين
التقليديه برئاسه نتنياهو والى المعسكر
المناول
هنا في المجتمع الاسرائيلي العام ولكن في
نهايه المطاف ولي اسباب تقنيه يعني اصبح
اليمين او اليمين الاكثر هو المهيمن في
الكنيسه بالنسبه
للعالم بشكل عام فاا الاخبار الجيده انه
لدينا هنا في اسرائيل رئيس حكومه عنده
تجربه اكثر من 20 سنه هل يستطيع هذا
الرئيس الحكومه ان يذم او
يجنس
العناصر الاختلاف عند مضيق قدما في حل
المشاكل في السيل هذا هو السؤال الكبير
امامنا
ولديه متاعب قضائيه ايضا شكرا لك همم
الباحث في المعهد الاسرائيلي الديمقراطيه
همم من تل ابيب شكرا لك